hello everyone I hope you're having an
excellent Saturday because we are back
at the Copa Blanca Saga we were back at
the 1918 tournament of New York this is
the second to last game that we are
going to show it's dodging off ski
versus Jose rule kappa blanka so facing
him for the second time in this
tournament couple Blanca still without a
loss and it's well he's just been having
one of the best tournaments in his
career and some of you have mentioned
that perhaps the capablanca saga has
been going on a bit too long and that
maybe we should switch to something else
but for those of you who share this
opinion there is a reason that we are
covering almost all of the important
games here in this saga and it's well I
will address this issue at the end of
the video but I do hope you watch it and
try it try to well understand why it's
very important that we cover it
thoroughly that being said let's check
out this photo one more time for those
of you who may be just joining us a nice
photo from the 1918 tournament of New
York it's from the around the eleven
couple Blanc of course faces Oscar highs
on board one and the rest of the
gentleman in the back so that being said
let's check out this very nice game so
Capablanca with the black pieces of sky
opens with d4 we have d5 Knight to f3
Knight to f6 and of course by now you
all know what's what's gonna be played
with east six the Queen's get a Queen's
Gambit the client is on the board Bishop
to g5 and now D captures on c4 grabbing
that c4 pawn and III of course preparing
to recapture with the bishop we have c5
by black and now this position is played
even today today most likely you would
see a bunch of captures on c4 move but
here cup sorry Janos he played Knight to
c3 and it's a move that hasn't been
played since so ever since this is a
game in 1918 this exact same position
has never been reached later but okay
with a six by Capablanca preparing to
solidify would be five it's possible
yanovskiy of course prevents that with a
4c capture Sundy for each capture Sundy
for Enda now Bishop to b4 just pinning
that knight kappa blanka
prepares to develop the queen and also
bring this Knight to e4 bushel captures
on c4 finally white recaptures the pawn
and now Queen to see
attacking the bishop on c4 you could
move the bishop go back to e2 but the
yellow ski goes about it differently
Queen te to developing the Queen while
defending on c4 and now as planned
now that the Queen has moved from the D
eight square Knight to e4 already
threatening to win some material here
and it is it is a very interesting idea
if highest went for this Queen captures
a need for move capablanca would most
likely go a bunch of characters and c3b
captures and recapture and c4 now
winning back material but it's not
really a problem for white here you know
so he could go night to D to just kick
the Queen back just you know nicely
castle and everything and if capablanca
was greedy enough to capture the c3 pawn
it's it wouldn't really be a problem
white can just castle and everything is
fine you you already have threats of
rook c1 the bishop on c8 is undefended I
mean it's just a much better position
for white the black king still has the
castle and without black actually having
the dark square bishop the end of skis
the dark square Bishop will you know run
all across the board unopposed
so an interesting idea pick up a blanca
but it
well white definitely has a lot of
compensation for for this seemingly
emitted phone what heist isn't
interested he plays castles and here
Knight captures an g5 Capablanca decides
okay I'm not interested in a poem I
think it's done in the center I want to
remove black strong dark square Bishop
with night capture some g5 and now comes
Queen to e7 with an attack on the night
on g5 and Queen to h5 already pressuring
black somewhat on the Kings side of
course you cannot castle due to queen h7
checkmate so first you have to address
this you can address it either via h6
although there's a there are a lot of
possibilities here if you play something
like h6 then the F pawn is pinned the
Knight captures on e6 could become a
problem
so Capablanca first pushes the Queen
back we have g6 Queen to h6 and now
Queen to f8 offering a trade but of
course hice isn't interested he's
controlling more space he's deciding the
tone of the battle here so Queen to 84
and Bishop the back to e7 opening this
Knight and here just Queen to g3 and
already you can see that we're only
move 16 but capablanca has a queen on f8
with the king still being in the center
now it's well if the if castles already
happen if the king was in g8 and the h8
rook was in the game then it wouldn't be
so strange to see the Queen on f8 but
with the king still still being in the
center of the board the Queen being on
f8 is is a bit bit of a problem you know
how are you going to develop here
so here capablanca has to make a choice
and this is what I'm going for with the
title of this video sometimes playing
the best move simply doesn't cut it here
even though there weren't any engines in
those days the best engine was probably
Capablanca himself here the strongest
reply by the engine is just Queen g7 and
hoping to castle but here what has the
very strong d5 reply and now after
castling you simple ad captures on e6f
captors on e6 and now Knight captures on
e6 so you would win this pawn here after
Bishop characters you would play Bishop
captures with check King moves and now
rook a to d1 and black has huge problems
developing his non-material it is only a
pawn but a very important pawn and you
don't have a good way of developing you
can't go 97 if you can night c6 then you
allowed the rook to infiltrate via route
to d7 pinning the bishop attacking the
b7 pawn and it's just a very ugly
position for black so here even though
it's the strongest line recommended by
the angel and of course Capablanca
thought about going Queen g7 and
castling it's it's even if it's the best
line it's simply not enough so a couple
Blanca tries to complicate first Bishop
captures and g7 remove one of the
attackers we have Queen captures on g5
and now comes Knight to d7 with ideas of
that if d5 comes and d5 is a very nice
option for white but most likely the
idea was if d5 then be 5 but then the
problem is what if d6 is played black
really doesn't have all that many
options you can play f4 open up the
central go rook e1 a lot of ways to
attack this King that's still in the
center and even if you capture the pawn
then comes Knight e4 and after the Queen
moves rook Fe one you can just yeah
threatened so much
and even if black castles is still not
enough rook a c1 already threatening to
win the Queen
check this would pick up the Queen and
there I mean there's just so many ideas
for white queen h6 followed by Knight g5
followed by checkmate on h7 if this
Knight ever moves then Knight to f6 is
an idea if you just move the Queen if
you don't lose the Queen then rook eat
d1 now with again so many threats you
can even remove the defender of the f6
create some threads there you can just
push the H pawn it's just a disgusting
position for black but somehow well with
this previous move we're a couple monk I
had to decide how to develop he captured
on g5 you know school recaptured and
then he played Knight to d7 and here
yanovskiy probably thought about d5 but
he was like I'm playing against
capablanca he's still without a loss you
know last time he lost was against Oscar
highs in that rice memorial of 1916
shortly Capablanca thought about d5 I
mean if he allows it it probably doesn't
work and he tried to play an even better
line he he decided to strike while the
iron's hot so to say and he played
Knight to d5 he says I'm not wasting any
time I'm just going straight for a cup
of lanka now of course the knight to c7
a huge threat
if you captured and you're immediately
lost wook everyone check the king has
nowhere to go you would have to either I
go Queen e7 which would be followed by
Queen captures checkmate or you would
have to give material rook captures or
Queen captures would be 5 with checking
d8 now we can capture Queen f6 check or
that Queen d7 now Bishop captures on d5
and I mean you're just dead lost here
there's no recovering from this position
but here after Knight to d5 he missed
one move from Cabo Blanco Blanco just
played Queen to d6 and here there is no
good follow up for white White had his
opportunity to go d5 but here I mean
your knight is just now under attack the
Queen freed the f8 square for the black
King so how do you continue here look Fe
one was played but now kappa blanka just
castles he says okay and there are no
threats here not not any dangerous once
at least so here we have Knight to f6 by
an auskey with Czech Knight captures we
have Queen captures and now just Queen
to d8 again offering a trade of Queens
we have Queen to e5 and now Bishop to d7
preparing
the goal Bishop to c6 to fully develop
and now you know of skew went d5 but
here d5 is not nearly as strong as when
d5 should have been played with each
capture Sun d5 Bishop captures on d5 and
now just Bishop to c6 Capablanca says
okay double my I mean ruin my pawn
structure here with the material on the
board is equal I can play this so Bishop
captures we have pawn captures and now
rook a2 b1 attacking the Queen and Queen
to b6 so you have this position and then
you had that position where we've shown
if d5 was played in the in the absolute
correct move then couple one who would
be in a lot a lot of trouble most likely
lost but who knows I mean he's kappa
blanka he might he might pull it off
somehow but still much better than this
playing this position against couple
monk over you're slightly better due to
the due to the connected points on the
Queen side whereas black has three point
islands but okay here
ya'know squeezes h4 he wants to play h5
h6 and deliver checkmate on g7 if
possible with rook a to b8 by Capablanca
going after the B to pawn and now just
h5 Janoski says I'm not interested in a
phone I'm still continuing my attack and
this is a something that often happens
when you have a great advantage your
opponent equalizes and then you want to
continue attacking even though you no
longer have any any rights to attack I
mean if you're if you're not better then
here you can just start an attack out of
nothing but okay it is a dangerous
position h6 is definitely a threat but
capablanca calculates precisely Queen
captures on b2 offering a trade of
Queens now of course there is this
tension here but Janoski just blocks
rope to d4 okay there's this problem
here that h6 is still a threat followed
by Queen to g7 checkmate
but rook fe8 attacking the Queen not
allowing white a move with h6 and white
now has to decide what to do the problem
is you can't move the Queen because your
roof is hanging here but you know sky
saw this and he prepared to trade the
Queen's Queen for two looks so Queen
captures on it with check rook captures
and rook captures with check King the g7
and now of course York
is under attack you don't have time to
do anything on the kingside you have to
move it
rook to h4 and here he has the correct
idea if Capablanca plays a slow move
like let's say five or something then h6
will secure white a draw because after
king to f6 you will go rook F or check
King g5 and now you will capture on f7
and here if you allow this rook captures
on h7 then this becomes a very dangerous
pass pawn so after King captures on h6
you will just go rook to e3 not allow
black to escape here and now you will
just check in Rakesh recheck Ruby 3
check rookie to be checked room g3 check
and you will have a draw by repetition
of moves so after Luke to h4 Capablanca
says no thank you
I'm still interested in playing this
game Quincy 1 check first we have King 2
h2 and now comes Queen to h6 not
allowing any captures here because the
rook is hanging so first
f4 we have G captures on h5 there there
is no problem here and the now comes
looked me five going after the h5 pawn
and here just Queen to d6 now putting
pressure as the queen is on the same
diagonal as the King and here you can
definitely go rook captures here couple
monk would just move the King rook
captures here and then you would have
this position where a white would have
grabbed a few pawns but then black would
start pushing the passed pawn the past C
pawn so this was couple on his idea but
you know ski has a different idea first
g3 and only now is he ready to capture
on h5 Capablanca played h6 with rook H
gap for Sun h5 now and now King to g6 by
Capablanca so now this rook cannot leave
the fifth ring because the King is also
attacking this rook we have G 4 but G 4
although it nicely protects the rooks
it allows capablanca a move that really
gives him a lot of advantage even though
Janoski has two looks for a queen
sometimes even that's not enough when
you allow Capablanca a free move like
this so feel free to pause the video
it's a very nice Saturday it's been you
know raining for so long it's such a
nice sunny day so at least here so feel
free to pause the video and try to find
this brilliant move
kappa blanka found in this position I'll
give you a couple of seconds for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations it's it's a move you
should almost never play but when you're
allowed to play then it usually wins the
game and for those of you who just wanna
enjoy the show of course the movies f6
so now here's the problem what do you do
here obviously have to move the rook the
problem is when a white played g4 the g3
pawn no longer guards the f4 points so
now if you move the rook you're gonna
lose this point and that's gonna be a
huge problem the only square where you
can go with the rook is rook to f5 but
now you have two rooks against the Queen
but this rook is never coming out of
there and this rook is stuck here
guarding the f4 point so although we
have two rooks they're really not doing
all that much and this was what couple
Blanca played so first Queen to d2 check
we have King to g3 and now comes Queen
to d3 check first delivering a few
checks to see how how white is feeling
queen king to have two now Queen to d2
check King to g3 and now paint that you
wanna check teams to g2 and now comes
Queen to d1 putting pressure on the a4
pawn but also threatening Queen captures
on g4 if if Queen captures on g4 happens
that's that's game for example if white
isn't careful if white play something
like a five tries to save the a pawn
then this is winning Queen captures here
after the King moves you can just grab
the rook it doesn't really matter
because the King and pawn endgame is a
super winning for black black piece of
material
there's no no questions that this is
winning so after Queen d1 with King to
g3 on offski defense and our first Queen
b3 check pushing the King back King f2
and only now capturing an aid for so now
white still has two rooks but Capablanca
has two passed pawns here the past C
pond and the passed a pond with King to
g3 Queen back to b3 with check King f2
and now comes Queen to c2 with check
King g3 Quinta e to now or going back at
it and now you are free to start pushing
your passports we have rook to H do you
know she wants to get that rock into the
game as quick as possible
Quinta e3 check and now King to h4 and
now finally c5 capablanca starts pushing
the pass bone with rook to c2 and not
see for excellence tempo because you
cannot capture the rook if you capture
it then of course the rook is lost but
you should be careful not to make a
mistake like Queenie to going for the
heater the rook or checkmate on h2
because a white defense both with rook
the c3 the rook cannot walk check what
you want to do is just queen f2 check
King goes here or queen f1 chef you will
pick up the rook and win the game so
after c-4 we have looked to a - and here
we have c3 the passed pawn simply
continues we have Luke - G - and now
comes Queen - efore attacking the rook
here on G 2 root 2 G 1 and here Queen 2
e 2 now the passport is again preparing
to march we have looked to G 3 and here
Capablanca played c2 and it was in this
position that w norske resigned the game
on 1:55 as there is nothing to do here
one well one obvious move how you could
stop the pony's rook to c5 but it simply
doesn't work again feel free to pause
the video here and try to find how you
punish punish white force for such a
silly move for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations you are an
excellent winner of rooks on a weekend
and for those who just want to enjoy the
show
of course Queen to h2 check the King has
no moves you have to block and the ones
the roadblocks now a queen f2 check
picks up the rook on c5 so it's not
another problem I just rode g3 Queen
captures next move you promote into a
into a second Queen and to win the game
easily so after c2 you can see such a
such a shame for Janoski
he played a brilliant game couple marker
played a few slow moves in the opening
you know couple unka and openings you
know we we can't state this enough but
he didn't take his chance you should
have played d5 immediately and then he
probably would have would have won the
game easily but then he gave a couple
Bank a chance capablanca didn't play the
strongest move he played the other one
he decided to trade in g5 and then you
know he managed to confusion arose and
this is how you sometimes have to play
you know to win games
it's just the way chess works but yeah a
wonderful victory for Capablanca in this
second to last game that we are showing
alas the last game Capablanca will play
is against balls of Kostich serving
grandmaster and we will be showing that
game as the last game of the 1918 new
york tournament before we had into the
five-game match with Borislav Kostich in
cuba hamana so that being said i just
want to address some of you have said
that maybe the couple monica saga has
been going on for too long but you know
yeah personally i enjoy every game that
I see couple of guys played because yes
you know 10 years ago when I read a book
about capablanca I was like wow this man
is a God I I mean he probably won every
game blindfolded but now when you see
the games when you see that you know she
actually had a chance to play d5 and
maybe even break a couple month as a
legendary not losing streak you know you
yeah you tend to appreciate his fighting
spirit
a lot more than just thinking that he
he's someone who can't make a mistake
and even when we were covering the Bobby
Fischer saga if you were following the
channel back then for example during the
candidates matches in 1971 when he
played against bent Larsen and then
marked a mono you know everyone knows
that he defeated them six to zero but
then when you see every game of the of
the candidates then you see that it was
a very very close call especially the
first three games in every match they
were like really really intense and then
okay when Bobby caught wind and he just
obliterated them all but still without
actually checking out all the games
you'd think like you know he just came
there you know played a few moves and
everything was over but it was a it was
a really huge fight so here I was very
impressed with the Norskies play here
really just uh I mean how do you not
play d5 there I mean okay when you play
against someone like Capablanca someone
who is immortal basically sure you're
thinking okay obviously kappa blanka so
d5 so i'm not gonna play that but still
it's it's i don't know to me it's just
really amazing and I really feel that we
should you know do the entire couple
Monica saga properly and see just what
happens so that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it and I do hope you enjoyed my
sort of explanation as to why we're not
rushing with the saga I would like to
thank Dano
patois rates RB who requested remain
anonymous Robyn via and the way when
Christensen for a contributor to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usually can check to my
previous videos you're thinking for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the capablanca saga we will
be checking out the women's candidates
tournament started so some nice games
I've heard have been played there and of
course checking up on your suggestions
and waiting for Norway LT box
championship so that's the game I will
see soon hope you enjoyed it and have an
excellent rest of your Saturday